[Music]
on this Tuesday night pro-russian
hackers allegedly targeting a Canadian
company what leaked documents from the
Pentagon reveal this is one of the most
damaging intelligence leaks plus
Ukraine's prime minister visits Canada
ottawa's fresh pledge for millions in
military aid a Canadian delegation in
Taiwan as tensions rise these people
live and breathe every day the
aggression of China our Jeff Semple
reports from Taipei troubling Trend
there's a lot of stories out there about
animals being abandoned in Parks how
inflation is costing some pets their
owners and the advice to people
struggling
plus pain in the ash a Russian volcano's
eruptions disruptions and entertainment
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha good
evening and thanks for joining us Canada
is stepping up with more support for
Ukraine as it defends against Russia's
full-scale war prime minister Justin
Trudeau announced the new measures today
while hosting his Ukrainian counterpart
in Toronto foreign
to the Canada Ukraine free trade deal
and more badly needed weapons 21
000 assault rifles 38 machine guns and
more than 2.4 million rounds of
ammunition
there are also more sanctions on both
Russian individuals and entities but the
two prime ministers had little to say
about that Trove of leaked classified
documents on the war in Ukraine as Eric
Sorensen reports there are new details
about just how wide Russia's reach may
actually be
leaked Pentagon documents have taken a
Canadian twist with Revelations that
alleged russian-backed hackers gained
access to a Canadian natural gas company
the Prime Minister acknowledged the leak
but downplayed the attack I can confirm
that there was no physical damage to any
Canadian energy infrastructure following
cyber attacks the Prime Minister did not
express alarm towards Washington but the
document's leak has embarrassed the U.S
and left officials scrambling to learn
how it happened how extensive it is and
whether there's still more to come we're
taking this very very seriously there is
a
uh no uh excuse for these kinds of
documents to be in the public domain
among the leaked documents are reports
that Ukraine is running low on
ammunition and that its air defenses are
vulnerable some documents were
apparently doctored to play up Ukrainian
losses suggesting Russian involvement
the U.S justice department is
investigating if it's an American
they're certainly a traitor and they
will be brought to Justice and the
Department of Justice is hot on the
trail on top of what was leaked
adversaries could be learning about
American intelligence methods
adversaries will try to discover how the
United States intelligence Community was
able to collect on them change their
setup and potentially potentially go
after spies safe to say this is one of
the most damaging intelligence leaks
this Century so far Ukraine's prime
minister visiting Canada today did not
address specific leaks about Ukraine
then Ishmael did say that Ukraine has
been working with allies and dealing for
years with Russian cyber attacks we work
closely with intelligence of European
Union United States Canada and we create
very strong
cyber security centers in Ukraine but
Ishmael was being warmly welcomed the
prime minister's website went down
Justin Trudeau suggested Russians were
likely behind it because of the
Ukrainian visit timing isn't surprising
but in case anyone was wondering uh
Russia being able to bring down an
official government of Canada web page
for a few hours is in no way going to
dissuade us from our un unshakable
support of Ukraine the PM treated the
dissident lightly but it seems it was a
message from the Russians and it was
received Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
a delegation of Canadian MPS has arrived
in Taiwan for a multi-day visit to meet
with political officials the trip funded
by the self-governing island comes on
the heels of a similar visit from U.S
lawmakers and is being seen as the
latest show of Western support for
Taipei as tensions continue to rise with
Beijing Jeff sample is in Taiwan for us
tonight Jeff
need to the Chinese military just
wrapped up three days of exercises
simulating an attack on this island
nation the largest drills since last
summer involving dozens of Chinese
warplanes and ships some of which remain
in this area according to the Taiwanese
government now those Chinese war games
were ordered in response to a visit by
the Taiwanese president to the United
States where she met with house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy among others defying
warnings from Beijing and in the midst
of those military Maneuvers and saber
rattling a Canadian delegation just
rolled into town 10 MPS representing
ottawa's four main political parties
just arrived here in Taipei at the
invitation of the Taiwanese government
which is footing the bill for the trip
the Canadians will spend the week
touring the region visiting military
sites and meeting with Taiwanese
political leaders including an event
Tuesday morning with the vice president
this visit is focused on security and
defense topping the agenda for
discussion is the Chinese government's
alleged foreign interference campaigns
this trip comes after months of reports
accusing Beijing of interfering in
Canadian elections and diaspora
communities which the Chinese government
denies and that type of interference is
something the Taiwanese say they've been
battling for years these people live and
breathe every day the aggression of
China whether it's military or whether
it's cyber or whether it's influence
operations Etc and so we've come here to
learn at that meeting here this morning
the Canadians presented the vice
president with a report that was
published last month by parliament's
special committee on Canada China
relations that report recommended Ottawa
Foster stronger trade and security ties
with Taiwan now when the report was
released the Chinese government accused
the committee of grossly interfering in
China's Internal Affairs so far Beijing
has not responded to the Canadians trip
here this week they're expected to meet
with the president tomorrow
need to Jeff Semple in Taipei Taiwan
thanks Jeff
Mass resignations have swept through the
leadership of the Pierre Elliott Trudeau
Foundation as the organization continues
to deal with the Fallout of its alleged
Connections in the ongoing foreign
interference controversy today the
foundation's CEO and its entire board of
directors stepped down sparking calls
from the opposition for an investigation
into the charity Mackenzie gray is
tracking this story for us from Ottawa
Mackenzie what reason did the foundation
give for this major change
while neither the Pierre elliotrudo
Foundation says it's the political
climate that made it impossible for
their board and CEO to continue in their
roles and the political heat ramped up
back in February after the Globe and
Mail reported that in 2016 the Chinese
Communist Party targeted the foundation
to try to Curry favor with prime
minister Justin Trudeau according to a
National Security Source now the alleged
plan was to have Chinese billionaire
Zhang bin seen here meeting with Trudeau
like a 200 000 donation to the
organization and the contribution would
be reimbursed by the Communist party now
last month the organization returned the
money to Zhang but that didn't stop the
conservatives from trying to tie the
foundation to the Prime Minister
directly the dictatorship in Beijing
gave the Trudeau Foundation two hundred
thousand dollars the Prime Minister has
benefited from dictator dollars through
the Trudeau Foundation
Mackenzie it's clear the conservatives
are trying to tie the prime minister
with the Trudeau Foundation but what is
Justin Trudeau's current relationship
with the organization
yeah neither the conservative claim on
this one doesn't hold water because
since becoming liberal leader Justin
Trudeau says he's had no connection with
the foundation but it is important to
note He's listed as a succession member
in their most recent annual report which
signals he could rejoin the organization
once his time in office is over now
despite the rights of the Nations
Trudeau says he's confident the
organization will continue its work I am
certain that the Trudeau foundation will
be able to continue to ensure that
research into the social studies and
Humanities at the highest levels across
Canadian academic institutions continues
now despite no current associations
Trudeau has leaned on others with ties
to the foundation including former CEO
Morris Rosenberg who the PM task with
writing report on foreign threats in the
2021 election and of course David
Johnson as well who was previously at
Trudeau Foundation member the former
Governor General he's been appointed as
Trudeau's special rapid Tour on
electoral interference and neither he'll
make a key decision for the Prime
Minister on whether or not there'll be a
public inquiry into election medal
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie
a chilling investigation is unfolding
near Calgary after spending days
searching a rural property police have
charged a 59-year-old man with several
counts of kidnapping and sexual assault
investigators believe the suspect was
targeting sex workers in a case with
Eerie similarities to the Robert Pickton
murders more than 20 years ago as
Heather urac's West reports Advocates
say Canada's laws are still putting
women in the sex trade at risk
police collect what appears to be a
french-made costume during search of a
rural property over the Easter weekend
potential evidence in what investigators
believe is a series of disturbing crimes
we have charged one man an investigation
into the alleged kidnapping drugging and
sexual assault of multiple women in the
Calgary area police say their
investigation began last month following
allegations that three women were
drugged taken to the rural property east
of Calgary and assaulted 59-year-old
Richard Robert mantha is facing 16
charges police say there had also been
three outstanding warrants out for
Mentha from Alberta RCMP also involving
sex crimes I think it's something that
the police are going to have to answer
to
why didn't they pursue the individual in
terms of outstanding warrants officers
may have concluded their search of this
rural property but the investigation is
far from over police believe there could
be more scenes and additional victims
especially with such a vulnerable
population sex workers at the center of
these crimes
this is far from the first time sex
workers have been targeted in violent
crime by the late 1990s Canada's worst
serial killer Robert Picton had preyed
upon prostitutes for years before he was
finally arrested people need to remember
that it is not against the lawn Canada
to be a sex worker
so
individuals need protection under the
law and the law does not provide them
with that in 2013 Canada's highest Court
ruled that laws against keeping a common
body house violated sex workers Charter
rights to safety but the laws were never
changed then in 2019 the country's
report into missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls also called
for Justice Reform little progress has
been made and now a new investigation
decades after Picton shows the
vulnerabilities for women in this
industry remain Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
police in Toronto say dozens of people
have been arrested hundreds of criminal
charges have been laid and 173 guns have
been seized following a year-long
cross-border gun trafficking
investigation dubbed project money Penny
the investigation involved four Canadian
police departments Canada Border
Services and several American law
enforcement agencies police say roughly
half the guns were seized in the greater
Toronto area with the other half being
found in Chicago wrapped in holiday
paper in the back of a vehicle destined
for Toronto
largest undefended border in the world
right we all know that so there's a
variety of smuggling techniques that are
used these Firearms are sold for three
four five hundred percent markup so
there's a demand for them
police say the guns originated from six
U.S states with a significant chunk of
them coming from Arizona
Rogers has announced plans to bring 5G
cell service to Toronto's entire subway
system the Telecom giant announced
Monday night it's set to acquire the
Canadian operations of Bai
Communications which had exclusive
rights to build a wireless network for
the Toronto Transit Commission since
2012. the announcement which also
included plans for expanded 9-1-1
service comes after a number of violent
attacks on Toronto's Transit System
I think more self-service would make
people feel safer and everyone needs to
be able to contact 9-1-1 or access their
data regardless of their provider
right now only Freedom mobile customers
have access to cell service in the
tunnels Roger says it will take about
two years to complete the project and
service won't be exclusive to Roger's
customers
new details about a mass murderer coming
up what police say a gunman in Kentucky
did just days before his attack plus Up
in Flames The Inferno in South Korea
sending hundreds from their homes
a huge Wildfire is burning up parts of
South Korea more than 500 people have
been forced to flee their homes on the
eastern coast the sky is orange and
covered in Thick Smoke strong winds are
Fanning the Flames but rain is helping
to ease the spread there are reports of
one death and more than a dozen
buildings destroyed it's believed the
fire was sparked when a tree fell onto
power lines
a warning this next story is disturbing
police in Kentucky have released body
cam footage from that mass shooting at a
bank in Louisville yesterday
as officers arrived on scene they were
shot at immediately officers ran into
the line of fire and shot the suspect
dead five people were killed two people
including an officer who recently
graduated from the police academy remain
in intensive care investigators say the
25-year-old suspect who was employed at
the bank legally purchased the weapon he
used last week
we know this shooter purchased an AR-15
rifle on April 4th we know he left a
note we know he texted or called at
least one person to let them know he was
suicidal and contemplating harm but we
don't have the tools on the books to
deal with someone who is in imminent
danger to themselves or to others the
assault rifle that was used to murder
five of our neighbors and shoot at
rescuing police officers will one day be
auctioned off
think about that
that murder weapon will be back on the
streets one day under Kentucky's current
law
Kentucky is one of 26 states that allows
most adults over 21 years old to
purchase and carry a firearm without a
license
food or Fido ahead options for tackling
tough choices when it comes to furry
companions
everything from groceries to gas is just
getting more expensive many Canadians
are feeling the pinch leading some to
make desperate decisions when it comes
to our families including our pets
Animal Advocates say help is available
Brittany Rosen reports on the options
out there for those who've fallen on
Hard Times
everybody this is Max he was recently
found in a Toronto park with nothing but
this note it said his owner had recently
lost his job and his home and was unable
to continue caring for the animal he has
one dog of a lot of families in our
community that are having these very
similar struggles pretzel following a
spike in pets adopted during the
pandemic animal rights Advocates say
many are now abandoning their
four-legged friends as they continue to
deal with increasing Financial pressures
there's a lot of stories out there about
animals being abandoned in Parks we know
that Rouge River Park has seen quite a
lot more pet abandonments and including
of animals who simply cannot survive
long outside like rabbits Camille
labchuk says while bunnies are a popular
Easter gift they often end up on the
streets she adds pet owners should turn
to their local Humane Society in times
of need as opposed to resorting to
abandonment they will in most cases
accept that animal care for them and
wave the surrender feet but this expert
stresses the need for families to better
budget their income so that it never
gets to that point the animal has to
come first and that's a terrible thing
to say that you miss a lunch you skip a
dinner your dog doesn't get to skip a
meal your dog doesn't understand what
inflation is while pet owners continue
to feel the pinch of inflation the Bank
of Canada is expected to hold its key
interest rate steady this week so if you
can continue to make ends meet for a
little bit longer things are expected to
improve according to economists for
every member of the family including
your furry companion 2023 might just be
slow but I don't think it's going to be
bad and I think things will bounce back
in 2024 as for pets like Max staff at
the Humane Society are working hard to
find him a forever home Brittany Rosen
Global News Toronto
Tupperware has been a kitchen staple for
decades but the company's future is
looking less than fresh it's seeking
investors after shares fell nearly 50
percent yesterday and warns it could go
out of business
[Music]
the nearly 80 year old company became
famous for its Tupperware parties the
company recently started selling
products at Target and branched out into
cooking products but sales have slid and
critics say products and distribution
methods have failed to stay relevant
against competitors
[Music]
Dusty disruption next the Eastern
Russian Villages smothered in volcanic
ash
[Music]
a surge of seismic activity in Colombia
has increased the chance of a major
volcanic eruption smoke is billowing
from the crater of this snow-capped
volcano and the government is racing to
get more than 2500 families out of the
hazard Zone many are refusing to leave
staying put to tend to crops and
livestock in 1985 an eruption killed
more than 25 thousand people
another large volcano is erupting in
Eastern Russia one of the country's most
active the Shiva luge volcano shot an
ash cloud 20 kilometers into the air
coating nearby Villages Redmond Shannon
reports
this is what you call making the most of
some gray skies
meet Ashman he says
or how about an ash Angel but before the
dusty fun people in part of Russia's Far
East awoke to total darkness it's 9 40
in the morning and it's completely darks
as this man as ash from shivaluch
volcano drifted down more than 10
centimeters of it sitting on the spring
snow it almost looks like a slice of
cake shivilage had been threatening an
explosion like this for years the
volcano sits in the middle of Russia's
Kamchatka Peninsula along the Pacific
Oceans volcano peppered ring of fire
this is pulverized Rock and fragments of
volcanic glass all mixed together so you
can imagine if you get that into your
lungs that is really bad volcanologist
Glenn Williams Jones says this is a
similar eruption to Mount Saint Helens
43 years ago flights over the region
should be far less impacted than the
Infamous Icelandic volcano ash cloud in
2010 which disrupted air travel for
Millions however because this eruption
sent Ash High into the stratosphere it
could have other Global effects not only
Europe not only not also hemisphere even
southern hemisphere could be impacted
this Russian climate scientist says the
eruption could temporarily cool the
planet's average temperature by around a
tenth of a degree but he warns its no
natural fix for global warming
just hidden in one year maybe two years
[Music]
as the dust settles the next concerns
for locals are the potential effects on
groundwater and the possibility that
heavy Ash could collapse through roofs
Redmond Shannon Global News London
and that is global national for this
Tuesday
dear Canada is Yarmouth Nova Scotia
thanks for watching Donna will be back
with you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]